aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función
igual a 250 sobre 25 más equis cuadrada
y lo que nos interesa es calcular el
área de todo todo esto que estoy
sombreando inclusive lo que no se ve
extendiéndose hacia la derecha para los
dispositivos de xy hacia la izquierda
para valores negativos de x estamos
hablando entonces de valores de x que
van desde menos infinito hasta más
infinito para empezar como denotamos
esto bueno va a ser la integral impropia
la integral impropia que va desde menos
infinito hasta más infinito de la
función 250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada
de x ahora ya hemos visto integrales y
propias donde uno de los límites va a
infinito pero qué haces cuando tienes
que el límite superior es infinito y el
límite inferior es menos infinito no se
puede tomar un límite hacia dos valores
la manera de atacar este problema es
encontrar el área la región que nos
interesa a través de dos integrales
impropias una entrega la propia base de
esta para encontrar el área de la región
que estoy marcando aquí en azul es la
integral impropia desde menos infinito a
0 va a ser igual entonces la integral de
menos infinito a 0 de la función 250
sobre 25 más x cuadrada de x y la otra
integral impropia la integral desde cero
a infinito de la función más la integral
de 0 a infinito de 250 sobre 25 más x
cuadrada
x ahora ya podemos calcular cada una de
estas integrales impropias la primera en
azul va a ser igual al límite cuando n
tiende a menos infinito de la integral
de n a 0 de 250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada
de x
más de aquí me estoy empezando a quedar
sin espacio más el límite aquí
voy a usar en mi aquí el límite cuando m
tiende a infinito del integral de 0 a m
de 250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada de x y
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
evaluar estas integrales definidas y
para eso tenemos que encontrar la anti
derivada de 250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada
calculemos entonces esas anti derivadas
lo voy a hacer aquí de lado izquierda
calculemos entonces la anti derivada de
250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada de x la
forma el integrando nos recuerda una
sustitución trigonométricas de la forma
de x sobre a cuadrada más x cuadrada
donde a cuadrado es igual a 25 entonces
vamos a hacer la sustitución x es igual
a 5 tangente de teta y luego haremos la
sustitución inversa y a partir de aquí
obtenemos entonces que x sobre 5 es
igual a tangente de teta dividimos entre
5 ambos lados vamos a despejar teta aquí
obtenemos entonces que teta es igual al
arco cuya tangente es x sobre 5 de tal
manera que esto de aquí es consistente
con esto si x es igual a 5 tangente de
tête à tête es igual arco cuya tangentes
x sobre 5 hagamos ahora la sustitución
de hecho primero tenemos que calcular de
x
tx vamos a ponerlo por acá para ponerlo
mejor acá abajo de x es igual derivó 5
tangente de 35 secante cuadrada de teta
de t está muy bien ya estamos completos
para hacer la sustitución vamos a
sustituir 250 de x 250 x de x sería 250
por 5 secante cuadra de teta por 5 sec
anticuada de teta de teta ese es nuestro
denominador el cual está dividido entre
25 más x cuadrada x es igual a 5
tangente de tete elevando al cuadrado es
25 tangente cuadrada de teta
simplifiquemos el integrando esto es
igual a la integral de 250 por 5 secante
cuadrada de teta sobre 25 que multiplica
a 1 + tangente cuadrada de teta de teta
podemos simplificar estos 250 entre 25
10 y aquí tenemos una tangente cuadra de
teta que es secante cuadra de teta esto
lo puedes verificar directamente
sustituyendo tangente cuadra detecta
como seno cuadra de teta sobre cose no
cuadra de te está escribiendo uno como
coseno cuadra de teta sobre coseno wade
te está haciendo la suma entidades
trigonométricas fáciles va a saber que
esto es secante cuadra de teta
esto es entonces secante cuadra de teta
tenemos entonces secante quad ett en el
denominador y secante cuadra desde el
numerador se simplifican dándonos uno al
final de cuentas esta integral es
simplemente 10 por 5 que 50 voy a sacar
el 50 del integral 50 integral de dt
está resolviendo este integral nos da 50
teta más se eso si queremos la anti
derivada general sin embargo con una
anti derivada particular nos basta pues
la vamos a sustituir en estas integrales
definidas que tenemos acá pero bueno
este es el resultado de la anti derivada
general
ahora vamos a sustituir lo que éste está
aquí tenemos que tener arco cuya
tangentes x sobre 5 así es que esto va a
ser 50 por arco cuya tangente
x sobre 5 + c estas son todas las anti
derivadas podemos escoger se iguala 0
para sustituirla en estas integrales
definidas hagamos eso lo que tenemos en
azul lo podemos describir como el límite
cuando n tiende a menos infinito de la
anti derivada una anti derivada de esta
función que es 50 arco tangente de x
sobre 5 y esto evaluado desde n hasta 0
a eso le agregamos más el límite cuando
m tiene infinito de 50 una anti derivada
de la función que es 50 arco tangente
arco novak o arco a arco tangente de x
sobre 5 y esto evaluado de 0 m de 0 m
deja de poner un paréntesis aquí para
darle más claridad a la expresión y esto
que va a ser igual
esto es igual al límite cuando n tiende
a menos infinito de 50 arco tangente de
0 sobre 5 menos 50 arco tangente de n
sobre 5 este es el primer límite a eso
le vamos a sumar más vamos a hacernos un
poco hacia la derecha límite cuando m
tiende infinito de 50 algo tangente de m
sobre 5 menos 50 arco tangente de 0
sobre 5
creo que ya te das cuenta hacia dónde
vamos vamos a evaluar esto y para
evaluar esto vamos a dibujar un círculo
unitario para poder visualizar la
función arco tangente la tangente la
tangente de un ángulo teta va a
corresponder a la pendiente del lado
terminal que describe el ángulo teta
veamos un ejemplo si éste es mi lado
terminal este es mi ángulo theta con
respecto a la parte positiva el eje x la
tangente va a ser la pendiente de esta
línea que es el lado terminal esa va a
ser la tangente de teta así que una
manera de calcular esto es si yo quiero
el arco tangente de cero necesito
encontrar entonces
el ángulo cuyo lado terminal es una
línea con pendiente cero y ese ángulo es
cero radiales así que el arco tangente
de 0 sobre 5 es 0 50 por 0 este término
se va a cero y también este término que
tenemos acá va a ser cero que nos queda
entonces nos queda
el límite el límite cuando n tiende a
menos infinito de menos 50 arco tangente
de n sobre 5
y eso más más el límite cuando m tiende
a infinito de 50 arco tangente de m
sobre 5 y esto a cuánto va a ser
calculemos el límite cuando n tiende a
menos infinito bueno cuando n tiene
menos infinito la pendiente de este lado
terminal va a ser cada vez más negativa
y cada vez más negativa aproximándose a
la parte negativa del eje y la cual
corresponde a un ángulo de teta igual a
menos y sobre 2 radiales así que el
límite cuando n tiende a menos infinito
de arco tangente de n sobre 5 el límite
cuando n tiende a menos infinito de algo
tangente de n sobre 5 esto hemos visto
que es menos y medios de tal manera que
x menos 50 esto nos va a dar menos 50 x
- y sobre dos y haciendo el producto
obtenemos que esto va a ser igual esto
va a ser igual a 25 y de manera análoga
para calcular el límite cuando me tiende
infinito de arco tangente de m sobre 5
aquí consideramos la dos terminales cuya
pendiente es cada vez más grande
positiva cada vez más grande
esto se aproxima a la vertical a la
parte positiva del eje y por lo que
cuando m tiende infinito el arco cuya
tangente es m sobre 5 se aproxima al
ángulo theta igual a pi sobre dos
radiales entonces este límite va a ser
igual a 50 por pi sobre 2 haciendo el
producto esto es igual a 25 y ya tenemos
entonces el área de la región que
tenemos aquí en azul es igual a 25 pi y
el área de la región que tenemos de
naranja es igual también a 25 pi
entonces para responder a la pregunta
original de cuál es el área bajo la
curva con la cual era una pregunta
bastante interesante sumamos el área de
las dos regiones 25 más 25 y para
obtener
50 y hemos concluido